[Music]
we did a little digging and found some
strange and interesting facts about
Disney's bunk'd so grab your s'mores and
gather round the campfire while we spill
the dirt on the cast and the show here
are ten strange facts in bunks we bet
you didn't know check out number one to
find out which cast member does an
awesome Shrek impression new here be
sure to click the like button and
subscribe to the things so you don't
miss our new videos social media stalker
you know how it is when you were about
to meet someone new and you were dying
to know everything about them beforehand
so maybe you check out their social
media profiles to find out what they're
like is that considered social media
stalking if so this bunked cast mate is
guilty Karan Brar shared that Disney set
up a mixer for the cast to meet its new
season two cast members but Karan went
to the stage the day before the mixer to
bring in some stuff from his dressing
room when he was there he saw the name
plates for the new cast mates dressing
rooms
so naturally he took pictures of their
dressing room doors so he could google
them and follow them on social media
before meeting them at the mixer
Karan admits that they may have been a
little creepy but don't worry he came
clean when he met Miranda and Kevin at
the mixer claiming he was just so
excited to meet them he couldn't help it
they seemed to have forgiven him and
they have all become buddies on set it's
true they say you never know who could
be googling you and checking out your
profiles fake set bunked is a show about
a rustic summer camp in the woods of
Maine so you think they filmed the show
in an outdoor location perhaps even a
real camp right wrong mini TV shows and
movies film outdoor scenes inside a
soundstage that is decorated and set up
to look like the characters are outdoors
they do this to give them more control
over the elements with an outdoor set
they can decide when the Sun Goes Down
the cast and crew can shoot nighttime
scenes during the day they don't have to
worry about wind rain or other weather
issues the indoor set also keeps
unnecessary noise from ruining their
takes and the wilderness it's hard to
tell a coyote to keep it down or a frog
to stop croaking in bunked Disney
created an artificial grass eater that
looks so real the set is lined with faux
trees and bushes leaves and of course
the cabins which are hollowed out to
make room for the camera equipment it
looks so cozy and campy we want to
circle around the
and roast marshmallows the set builders
and designers did a great job it's hard
to believe it's not real ah the magic of
Hollywood the cast missed from sometimes
being a child star is not all it's
cracked up to be
most child actors have onset tutors
since they are working these kids miss
out on normal school rituals like riding
the bus getting your milk stolen by a
senior sporting events and dances it's
something most of these actors were
willing to give up because they love
performing
but it has to be hard sometimes like on
prom night while most teenagers are
dressing up in tuxedos and gowns
applying heavy amounts of zit cream
picking up corsages and boutonnieres and
awkwardly asking their highschool crush
to be their date Disney stars are on set
working this isn't lost on Disney
executives according to Quran Brar
Disney hosts dances and mixers for the
cast and their families and friends
while it's not exactly your normal
teenage rite of passage the cast enjoys
these little get-togethers Disney
doesn't allow any press with these
events so the cast can be free to just
be teenagers Karan Brar said it's one of
his favorite things about being part of
the Disney family it's important to
allow the cast a little downtime to just
be themselves it seems like most of the
cast is skipping the awkward phase and
going right on to stardom this is not
Peyton lists dream job kids often have
hopes and dreams about what they will
become in the future young Steve Jobs
saw his first computer when he was 12
years old and knew from that moment on
that he wanted to work with computers
Oprah got into public speaking at a
young age and even won a beauty pageant
so when Disney asked Peyton what her
dream job was when she was little
they were pretty surprised by her
unusual answer she said she really
wanted to be a bus driver Peyton's share
that it was her biggest dream to drive
the bus and chat with her friends since
she is a self-proclaimed social
butterfly she thought this would be the
best way for her to talk to her friends
without getting in trouble with the
teachers apparently she was in trouble a
lot from talking to her friends too much
in class
sounds pretty logical right can you
imagine Peyton lists driving a school
bus when she gave this interview she was
studying to take her driver's license
test
she was pretty confident that she would
pass the driving test but she admits she
will have to work at keeping her eyes on
the road and chill out with the chatting
while driving
Kevin gee Quinn auditioned for American
Idol many true fans already know that
Kevin G Quinn who plays the role of
Xander McCormick on bong
auditioned for American Idol in 2013
what fans may not know is that he was
one of the youngest contestants to make
it as a Hollywood group Brown finalist
he performed five times for executive
producers and celebrity judges Keith
Urban Mariah Carey Nicki Minaj and Randy
Jackson while Kevin didn't make it to
the top finalists he was among the top
60 males in the country we watched his
adorable audition interview and can't
believe they passed on this future star
and the rendition of Skinny Love is
pretty fantastic
Kevin gee Quinn isn't the only superstar
American Idol rejected
Kevin sits in good company with Kobe
calots Amber Riley and 2016 Grammy
nominee Tori Kelly
Simon passed on Tori because he says he
got her voice was annoying guess America
doesn't always agree with the judges
Kevin did a little campfire singing and
guitar playing in the show and fans
loved it it makes us wonder if American
Idol regrets passing on this future star
is a recording contract in Kevin's
future maybe even a Grammy nomination
only time will tell
fans are glad he didn't give up on his
dreams after such a major rejection
Disney let go of some of the cast's for
season 3 speaking of rejection when
Disney announced it would be reviewing
bunks for a third season the news was
bittersweet for some fans in a statement
released from Disney Channel they
announced that Kevin G Quinn who plays
Xander Nathan arenas who plays for hay
and Nina Liu who plays Tiffany will not
be back for season 3 according to Disney
they said the producers reassessed the
story for season 3 and had to make tough
creative and casting choices they wanted
to introduce new characters to the show
the network said they appreciate the
contributions made by Kevin Nathan and
Nina and wish them well tough blow guys
but as Kevin can confirm sometimes
rejection leads you to something even
bigger and better
according to Kevin's Twitter feed he is
already working on something new though
he didn't say what it was Nathan is
making fun videos on Instagram and
YouTube involving food and you guessed
it magic tricks Nina Lou starred in a
made-for-tv movie called an American
Girl story it looks like these young
stars are going to bounce back and are
just fine way to keep going guys will
always have camp those were some good
times
Nathan arenas idols are Jim Carrey
Johnny Depp and David Blaine Nathan
arenas who plays Jorge on the show loves
comedy almost as much as he loves magic
that would explain why when asked by
twist magazine
who his role models are he said Jim
Carrey Johnny Depp and David Blaine
Nathan said he loves Jim Carrey's power
with comedy but he really enjoys his
inspirational speeches Nathan loves how
Johnny Depp can switch in and out of
certain characters with ease then there
is David Blaine
Nathan's magic role model Nathan said
that he loves that David Blaine is not
afraid of death he's read a lot of books
about Blaine and he's intrigued by the
fact that he has risked his life so many
times just for the sake of entertainment
he fills David Blaine has been able to
beat life itself and he finds that
absolutely incredible since Nathan does
magic - it makes sense that he would
admire David Blaine but who is Nathan's
number one role model his mom
Nathan says although she's a single mom
she has done so much for him and his
sister he said his mom taught him to
believe that anything is possible
according to Nathan's mom the word
impossible should not even be a part of
anyone's vocabulary smart lady Miranda
may played a young Melissa McCarthy
Miranda may is wicked talented not only
does she make fans laugh on Disney's
funk she also makes people laugh from
the stand-up comedy stage Miranda has
performed on the stage at Brea Improv
Harrah's hotel in Las Vegas and the
Hollywood improv Miranda was cast in the
Heartbreak Kid and performed alongside
Eva Longoria and Jason Biggs in the film
lower learning but perhaps one of
Miranda's most interesting roles was
when she played a young Melissa McCarthy
on the TV show Samantha who when asked
to her comedy Idol was she said Lucille
Ball apparently the stage next door to
where she filmed bunked was the old
stage for I Love Lucy that explains why
she's so funny Miranda has her best
friend Peyton laughing non-stop these
two besties have slumber parties at each
other's houses at least once a week
here's another interesting facts Peyton
and miranda share the same birthday how
cool is that it might surprise you to
know that they didn't think they were
going to like each other at first but
Miranda is so funny and down-to-earth
what's not to like
anyone who loves Lucy can play a young
Melissa McCarthy and does a killer
Shakira impression is definitely best
friend material those slumber parties
must be epic racial stereotyping and
inappropriate language a lot of parents
have major issues with this show on
common sense media many commented on
what they perceived as racial
stereotyping and inappropriate language
for a kids show according to these
ratings from some disgruntled parents
the show encourages
respectful behavior one parent pointed
out an episode where a camp counselor
commented about a wild night in which
she did not get what she wanted from the
candy supplier to the camp so she
decided not to purchase any more candy
for the camp from this man after that
one kid asked why the kids have to be
punished call her ugly and said no one
wants to date her way harsh dude the
parent was not happy when she saw that
she said she thought poor behavior and
rudeness with piped and laughter was not
for her family another parent was not
happy with what was perceived as a
countless display of stereotypes in the
show Nina lose character Tiffany Chen is
very smart and obsessed with schoolwork
according to this discerning parent half
her jokes are about her as the parent
puts it tiger mom this parent claims
this is a stereotypical label and was
not amused
parents definitely feel like Disney has
some work to do in order to make the
show more family-friendly hidden talents
of the cast you may not know it but the
cast of bunk'd has some strange and
interesting hidden talents in various
interviews the cast shared each other's
bizarre skills for example Nathan arenas
can perform close-up card magic he plays
the guitar piano and drums and he's a
vegetarian that's one talented dude
although according to his co-star Skye
he's also pretty messy Miranda may can
do a spot-on impression of Kim
Kardashian crying hilarious and
according to her cast mate and best
friend Peyton lists
Miranda also does awesome impressions of
Shakira and Britney Spears this girl is
unstoppable according to Miranda Mae her
cast mate Lincoln is an excellent golfer
Kevin Quinn does a pretty awesome
impression of Shrek and according to his
co-star Skye he is the most hyperactive
and funniest cast member Tessa netting
and Peyton lists can do the cup song at
double speed Skye Jackson admits to
being the biggest prankster on set as
for who takes the most selfies it may
surprise you to find out it's Nina Lou
the whole cast loves to play basketball
together though according to karan brar
kevin is the basketball champ pretty
interesting right and that's it for our
10 strange facts about Disney's bunked
you probably didn't know thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]